ever feel like life's lessons come too
late what if I told you the wisdom you
need is already within you you just need
to unlock it here's the truth the most
expensive tax you pay isn't financial
it's the wisdom tax years spent learning
lessons that could have been learned in
minutes your mental models are the
invisible operating system running your
life they determine what you see as
possible or impossible but here's the
game Cher you can upgrade them think
about your attention your most valuable
currency
in a world designed to fracture it
managing your focus is a
superpower and it's not about willpower
it's about designing systems that make
success inevitable relationships they're
shaped by unstated expectations most
arguments aren't about the dishes
they're about respect contribution and
appreciation and success it's not about
following prescriptions it's about
reverse engineering what works and
adapting it to your unique path the key
to Lasting change identity instead of
saying I want to write a book say I'm a
writer ready to stop paying the wisdom
tax watch the full video and discover
how to transform knowledge into action
starting today